Je venais juste d'être diplômé deux ans auparavant.
Å l'époque,
tout ce que je savais sur Ebola venait d'un article d'une page
que j'avais lu à l'université.
Je considérais la maladie si dangereuse
que cette page m'avait convaincu de fuir l'hôpital
au moment où j'entendrais parler d'Ebola.
Mais, ce jour-là, je restai et choisis d'aider.
Comme beaucoup d'autres professionnels de santé courageux.
Mais nous allions en payer le prix.
Beaucoup de personnes et de professionnels étaient des contacts à haut risque.
C'est-à-dire à 21 jours de la maladie ou de la mort.
Notre système de santé était fragile,
nos employés manquaient de compétences et d'entraînement.
Dans les semaines et les mois qui suivirent,
énormément d'opérateurs de santé contractèrent la maladie.
Plus de 400 infirmières, médecins et autres professionnels furent contaminés.
Malheureusement, mon ami, le chirurgien
qui avait identifié correctement les symptômes du premier cas
fut parmi eux.
Le 27 juillet, la présidente du Liberia
imposa la quarantaine dans les zones les plus touchées.
Elle ferma toutes les écoles et les universités
et supprima beaucoup d'événements publics.
Quatre jours après,
les forces de paix de l'ONU
quittèrent le Liberia, la Sierra Leone et la Guinée
à cause d'Ebola.
Au mois d'août, six mois après,
des centaines d'individus mouraient chaque semaine.
Les gens mouraient dans les rues.
Les mois suivants,
l'Afrique de l'ouest perdit des milliers de personnes à cause d'Ebola.
Au mois d'août, je rejoignis une équipe pour organiser une unité de traitement
à l'hôpital JFK à Monrovia.
J'étais le responsable de la deuxième unité thérapeutique Ebola de la ville.
L'unité donna de l'espoir à des milliers de patients, familles et communautés.
Je ne dispensais pas que des soins, j'étais en face d'Ebola.
Vivre tous les jours le risque de contact avec le virus Ebola
pendant la période de l'épidémie
a été l'une de mes pires expériences.
Je comptais 21 jours chaque jour.
Je vivais chaque instant en anticipant la manifestation des symptômes.
Je prenais ma température plusieurs fois.
Je me douchais avec de l'eau javellisée,
plus concentrée que ce qui est recommandé.
Je javellisais mon téléphone, mes pantalons, mes mains, ma voiture.
Mes vêtements furent javellisés.
Ces jours, on était seul,
tout le monde avait peur de toucher quelqu'un.
Chacun était un risque potentiel.
Toucher les aurait rendus malades.
J'étais stigmatisé.
Mais s'il en était ainsi pour moi, qui n'avais point de symptômes,
imaginez-vous quelqu'un qui les avait,
quelqu'un qui avait Ebola.
Nous apprîmes que pour vaincre Ebola,
il fallait suspendre certaines règles de la société.
En août, notre présidente déclara l'état d'urgence
et elle suspendit certains droits.
La police nationale soutint aussi notre travail
pendant la période de crise.
En février 2015, des membres des gangs furent isolés
dans notre unité.
Ils étaient connus comme les VIP boys de Monrovia,
de petits toxicomanes épouvantables.
Leur présence aurait pu engendrer une très grande peur,
même s'ils ne pouvaient pas porter légalement des armes.
Ils passèrent une quarantaine de 21 jours dans l'unité sans être arrêtés.
Nous avons dit à la police :
« Si vous les arrêtez ici,
ils ne viendront plus, ils ne seront pas soignés,
et Ebola continuera à se propager. »
La police accepta, nous pûmes traiter les VIP boys
et ils n'eurent pas à craindre d'être arrêtés dans l'unité.
Pendant l'épidémie, l'Afrique de l'Ouest eut 29 000 cas.
Plus de 11 000 personnes moururent,
parmi lesquelles 12 de mes collègues de l'hôpital JFK à Monrovia.
En juin 2016, 23 mois après la mort de mon premier patient d'Ebola,
le Liberia déclara la fin de l'épidémie.
Nous croyions qu'une fois l'épidémie terminée,
les problèmes aussi seraient finis.
Nous espérions un retour à la normalité.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons plus de 17 000 survivants en Afrique de l'Ouest.
Gens qui ont développé la maladie Ebola,
ils y sont passés et ils ont survécu.
Le taux de survie pour nous était un succès :
la fin de la souffrance pour le patient, la joie pour leur famille.
Chaque départ de l'unité était un moment de joie.
Du moins, nous le croyions.
La meilleure description d'un départ
et un rare aperçu de la vie après Ebola
a été exprimé de façon saisissante par mon meilleur ami
et confrère Philip Ireland lors d'une interview au Times.
Au moment de sa sortie, il a dit :
« Il y avait beaucoup de monde de l'hôpital JFK :
ma famille, mon frère aîné, ma femme étaient là.
D'autres médecins étaient là également et des gens des médias.
Je me sentis comme Nelson Mandela, c'était comme « Un long chemin vers la liberté »,
je marchais et levais les bras au ciel,
remerciant Dieu pour avoir sauvé ma vie. »
Philip dit : « Puis, j'ai vu autre chose.
Beaucoup pleuraient, beaucoup étaient contents de me voir.
Mais lorsque je m'approchais, ils s'éloignaient. »
Pour les survivants d'Ebola, la société semble s'éloigner,
même lorsqu'ils essayent de mener une vie normale.
Pour ces survivants, la vie est comparable à une urgence sanitaire.
Ils peuvent souffrir de douleurs dans les articulations.
La souffrance souvent décline progressivement.
Pourtant, beaucoup continuent d'endurer une douleur intermittente.
Des survivants sont aveugles, d'autres ont des handicaps neurologiques.
Des survivants expérimentent chaque jour la stigmatisation.
Beaucoup d'enfants sont orphelins.
Des survivants souffrent de trouble de stress post-traumatique.
Certains survivants n'ont pas l'opportunité d'étudier.
Les familles aussi peuvent être divisées par la peur d'Ebola.
Il n'y a pas de remède définitif contre la transmission sexuelle d'Ebola.
En revanche, la prévention a du succès.
Nous avons travaillé dur sur les tests du sperme,
les comportements, la promotion de la contraception et la recherche.
Depuis un an, nous n'avons pas eu de cas de transmission sexuelle.
Mais des survivants ont perdu leur femme
qui avait peur d'être infectée par Ebola.
Voilà comment des familles ont été déchirées.
Un autre énorme défi pour les survivants d'Ebola,
c'est de recevoir des soins.
En théorie, au Liberia, les services de santé sont gratuits.
En pratique, notre système manque de subventions et de capacité
pour dispenser les soins à qui en a besoin.
Des survivants ont attendu des mois pour une intervention
pour soigner la cécité due aux cataractes.
Quelques-uns ont vécu à nouveau une expérience traumatique
lors de l'admission quand on les a testés pour Ebola.
Certains survivants ont vu décaler ou différer leur admission
à cause du nombre réduit de lits.
Pas de lit pour un nouveau patient.
Ce n'est ni la politique officielle, ce n'est pas toléré,
mais les gens sont encore inquiets d'une reprise sporadique du virus Ebola.
Le résultat pourrait être dramatique.
J'ai vu plusieurs fois Beatrice, qui a survécu à Ebola.
Elle a 26 ans.
Beaucoup dans sa famille ont été infectés, elle a heureusement survécu.
Mais à partir de ce jour en 2014, lorsqu'elle a quitté l'hôpital,
remerciant le personnel,
sa vie n'a plus été la même.
A cause d'Ebola, elle est devenue aveugle.
En 2014, un enfant de deux ans d'un très cher ami à moi
a été hospitalisé avec ses parents dans l'unité Ebola à Monrovia.
Heureusement, ils ont survécu.
L'enfant a maintenant 3 ans,
mais il ne peut pas rester debout, ni marcher, ni parler.
Il a un retard de croissance.
Il y a des expériences cachées, des histoires qui ne sont pas racontées.
Les survivants d'Ebola méritent notre attention et notre soutien.
La seule façon de battre cette pandémie
est de garantir de gagner cette dernière bataille.
Notre meilleure chance est d'assurer
que chaque survivant reçoive les soins dont il a besoin
sans être stigmatisé et sans frais personnel.
Comment peut-on considérer que la société est guérie
lorsque l'identité d'une personne
est définie par son hospitalisation à cause d'Ebola ?
Est-ce qu'une maladie eue dans le passé
peut devenir son identité,
un statut sur son passeport
qui l'empêche de voyager pour trouver des soins à l'étranger ?
La carte d'identité qui empêche les soins.
Ou qui l'empêche d'avoir des relations avec son épouse.
Ou qui le met à l'écart de sa famille, de ses amis, de chez soi.
Ou qui l'empêche d'exercer son travail,
pour avoir de quoi manger ou un toit pour protéger sa famille.
Quel est le sens du droit à la vie
quand notre vie est sombrée par le stigma et les barrières que ce stigma érige?
Si on n'a pas de réponses à ces questions, en Afrique de l'Ouest,
notre travail n'est pas terminé.
Les Libériens sont un peuple résilient.
Nous savons comment relever un défi, même catastrophique.
Le plus beau souvenir de l'épidémie
se focalise sur les gens qui ont survécu
mais je n'oublie pas les infirmières, les médecins, les bénévoles,
les équipes qui ont travaillé dur
et mis en danger leur sécurité pour rendre service à l'humanité.
Beaucoup y ont perdu la vie.
Pendant le pire moment de la contagion,
ce qui nous aida à poursuivre ce quotidien dangereux à l'hôpital d'Ebola
fut la passion de sauver des vies.
Ai-je eu peur pendant l'épidémie ?
Bien entendu.
Mais pour moi, la chance de protéger la santé publique
et de protéger les communautés, la mienne et les autres, c'était un honneur.
Lorsque le danger est devenu pressant, notre humanité se fit plus forte.
Nous avons bravé nos peurs.
La communauté médicale en travaillant ensemble arrêta Ebola
et ça,
c'est grâce à ça que je sais
que nous pouvons vaincre
dans nos cœurs, dans notre esprit et dans nos communautés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)